seguramente hablar de economía en
directo américa ya está conmigo en el
estudio daniela brandon daniela félix
lunes bienvenida a nuestro estudio
comenzamos con una noticia pues que no
ha parado porque de ver gran bola tumbar
la fuerza las bolsas asiáticas año hola
raúl buenos días feliz lunes pues mire
los inversionistas asiáticos se
despertaron con una noticia bastante
escueta pero muy diciente y es que este
grupo de belgrano se suspendió
temporalmente la cotización de sus
acciones en la bolsa de hong kong y es
que de los 300 mil millones de dólares
que acumula en deudas tiene que devolver
unos 37 mil millones antes de que
termine el primer semestre de 2022 el
diario global times que es un periódico
chino afín al gobierno participó o
anticipó mejor que deber grande va a
vender un 51 por ciento de su negocio de
administración de propiedades por
alrededor de 5 mil millones de dólares a
una compañía llamada hopson development
este sería el acuerdo más grande de este
tipo en la historia de esta compañía
la incertidumbre raúl sobre el que
alguna vez fue el grupo inmobiliario más
vendido en china ha inquietado de los
mercados financieros por las
consecuencias que podría tener y de la
que hemos hablado muchas veces y cómo se
traduce esta inquietud de las bolsas
daniela pues mira las bolsas asiáticas
por supuesto se hicieron sentir el día
de hoy el índice de referencia hang seng
de la bolsa de hong kong cayó más del 2
por ciento mientras que japón acumula su
sexta jornada consecutiva a la baja y en
europa las bolsas operan mixtas y sin
grandes cambios pendientes además de una
reunión de la opep para definir si
mantienen o suben la producción de
petróleo esto para estabilizar los
precios y europa nos venimos a nuestro
continente al continente americano el
gobierno de mexico quiere controlar el
litio como así bueno llegó ya a manos
del congreso un proyecto de reforma
constitucional del presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador que es como un plan
b
debido a que las propuestas que ya había
presentado antes pues han quedado
encallada en los tribunales el
mandatario ha querido darle más peso al
estado en el mercado eléctrico pero los
inversionistas privados se quejan de que
se perdería la competencia por ejemplo
en este proyecto de reforma el gobierno
pretende que
federal de electricidad abastezca el 54%
del mercado como una manera de controlar
los precios que hay a precios justos
dice el gobierno el 46% restante si
quedaría en manos de privados pero
además como usted lo dice el proyecto
establece que el litio y los demás
minerales estratégicos no van a ser
entregados en concesión sino que serán
explotados directamente por el estado
mexicano sólo permanecerán las 8
concesiones que ya existen siempre y
cuando acrediten que ya iniciaron un
proceso de exploración donde pasamos a
nuestro otro tema de economía del día de
hoy porque eeuu y china se están
acercando con miras a mejorar su
situación comercial bueno estos dos
países llevan varios meses pues bien
distanciados en relaciones comerciales y
beijing ha incumplido con los acuerdos
según dice en eeuu a los que se habían
llegado ahora le voy a explicar en qué
consistieron estos acuerdos mire se
trata de un acuerdo de fase 1 que se
firmó en diciembre de 2019 y que expira
al finalizar de este año
asia y china se comprometió a impulsar
las compras de bienes agrícolas y
manufacturas estadounidenses por 200.000
millones de dólares anuales pero hasta
ahora sólo se ha cumplido el 62 por
ciento de ese objetivo a cambio de esto
eeuu había comprometido a reducir a la
mitad el arancel del 15 por ciento que
había impuesto a productos chinos por
120.000 millones de dólares anuales
ahora de acuerdo con información
suministrada a agencias por la casa
blanca la representante comercial de
eeuu que hace venta y buscará un acuerdo
o un nuevo acercamiento mejor con su
homólogo en china y no descartará acudir
a nuevos aranceles para presionar el
cumplimiento de lo que ya se había
acordado hasta el momento y para nuestro
segundo bloque económico de directo
américa le voy a decir que no se debe la
cifra del día daniela y tenemos más
información ahora más adelante ahora
bajo nuestro reportaje le parece claro
que decíamos